in the lobby of Ramsey solutions Tom and
Norma are here from Glendale Arizona hi
guys how are you good great Dave welcome
so all the way from Phoenix yes I love
it welcome to Nashville good to have you
here to do your debt free scream so how
much have you paid off 204,000 Oh Lee
lonely how long did that take for years
for years and making what kind of money
60,000 so what kind of 60,000 you must
have sold something I paid my house off
you paid your old ass off you sold out
sold the house ok Wow so tell me your
story uh it started quite a long time
ago but my wife was had multiple
sclerosis and she was in nursing home
for 10 years mm-hmm nuh she didn't know
exactly what was going on but at that
time you know we had a lot of expenses
with a nursing home and with you know
care expenses in the house I took care
of rittenhouse for you a year and a half
but the biggest thing was you know three
years ago she got a bit sore and it was
pretty bad and she got Marissa and so I
was expecting her to that I you know I
didn't know and you know so I didn't
know where is going to get money for
expenses to bury her you know I mean
it's like wow you know what can I do Wow
and so you know we I you know again I
started on this plane about four years
ago I've been listen to you for a long
time with her but I knew that I had to
do something it was different you know
and so you know had credit card in fact
the last credit card I wanted my
daughter to go on the plan we got
married my new wife were here in July
and on July eleventh and so when did
your first wife passed she passed a year
and eight seven months ago okay all
right and so normal and you just got
married yeah congratulations on that
thank you so so through all of this
immense stress to say the least you
still managed to pay off your home
okay and did you end and then you sold
it or tell me how that part of it works
yeah we I got it down to like 80,000 and
then you know my wife died and and you
know I got it down to 80,000 right after
she died maybe a year and a year and a
half then norm and I we I came home on
that or called Norma I went on vacation
I said well you want to get married and
moved to Reno and install the house Oh
enormous like what yeah that's some kind
of a proposal he's a real romantic
kidney oh that's fun and she said yes
yeah she said yes thought we went to
Reno and then came back to Phoenix cuz
all of our grandkids are all there okay
so rosy sold the house at that point and
that finished off the debt yes oh my
goodness so and then you now you've
moved back to Phoenix and are you still
out of that completely yes did you buy
home with we she owns a home she's been
gone for a long time Oh another reason
why I marry her because okay so there
there you go Norma now we got the true
story like I said he's a real romantic
so Norma he called you up and said you
want to get married did you tell me had
to be debt free hmm say yes yes okay
yeah alright that's fine very cool so
now you moved back in your enormous
place and it's paid for yes and because
she was smart long before she met you
okay and and then you've got the cash
from the house as well yes so you guys
have got a pretty good nesting a good
start on this next chapter to your life
yeah and I retired I don't know if I
mentioned that too okay I'm retired last
month so why don't you know I want to
travel but she wants to like to work but
I keep telling you don't have to work
you don't have to work yeah we got all
these grandkids we can run around the
world see stuff yeah that's right that's
fun well maybe she can do some work and
in between y'all can do some travel yes
that's good well congratulations how's
it feel to have no debt it's awesome
David so awesome it's just amazing I
mean you've gone through a tremendous
process here with with your first wife
with the MS and then her passing and
then the sale moved to Reno
back married retired I mean a lot has
happened to you in four years yes it
really has oh yeah you're sad that's it
is a new chapter the sun shining but I
want to I want to start your class right
away back in Phoenix uh my friend Dan
Bernard he has helped me with my
finances with investing my money and he
told me I could work out of his office
and do your class oh cool and he wants
to be an ELP also okay so very cool
we're gonna try to you know make that
work good good well you certainly start
the class at your church to that's
really good way to do it yeah that's
very fun very neat well congratulations
guys I'm product very very nice alright
Tom and Norma from Glendale Arizona
Tom's story and Norma joins it at the
last minute here that's awesome so count
it down let's our 204,000 paid off in
four years quite a journey making 60,000
a year count it down let's hear a
debt-free scream three two one where Dad
free
congratulations you guys well done well
done well done